hey guys Pete here today I'm going to do
one last better call Saul bonus video as
we wait for the finale of season 5 it's
time to talk about Eduardo Lalo
Salamanca as we approach the end of
better call Saul season 5 Lalo has
become the most interesting villain in
the current story and this has led some
fans to declare that he's the best
villain the Breaking Bad universe has
ever produced the hype is definitely
real Lalo is a great character and a
great villain officially I think it's
too early to tell where a hill ranked
against so many other great villains
this franchise has introduced us to but
I think now is a great time to look at
what makes him so compelling to borrow a
quote from the man himself when he first
meets Jimmy he tells him you're the guy
for this in many ways I believe Lalo is
the guy for this and that's what I want
to explore before we dive in this is
your spoiler warning this video will
talk about everything that's happened in
better call Saul through season 5
episode 9 and everything that happened
in Breaking Bad if you haven't made it
that far then this video will be filled
with massive spoilers that you won't be
able to unsee Lalo Salamanca is a late
comer to the origin story of Saul
Goodman his first appearance doesn't
happen until the 8th episode of season 4
he comes to Albuquerque to help with the
Salamanca family business which has
experienced some setbacks in season 2
his cousin
Tuco Salamanca is sent to prison after
nacho Varga hires Mike to set him up in
season 3 his uncle Hector Salamanca
becomes permanently disabled after he's
poisoned by nacho the cousins
Leonel and Marco Salamanca come to visit
their uncle after a stroke but end up
having to flee back south of the border
to Mexico after attacking the Espinosa
gang their departure leaves nacho who by
this time is under Gus Frings influence
in charge of the Salamanca family
operations in New Mexico that opens the
door for a la lo to arrive and get
things in order for the Salamanca's
prequel shows are hard to make because
the end of the story there based on has
already been told
better call Saul has always excelled
in light of that it never ceases to
amaze me how they come up with ways to
make the journey to that end compelling
and full of surprises the show has
always been impressive in its ability to
take things that seem minor from
Breaking Bad and turn them into
something interesting there have been so
many little details and throwaway lines
from Breaking Bad that the writers have
picked up and run with Lalo Salamanca is
one of the best examples of that
the name Lalo first comes up in Breaking
Bad season 2 episode 8 which shares the
title better call Saul with our current
series the episode is best remembered as
the introduction of Saul Goodman but it
also serves as the origin of both nacho
Varga and Lalo Salamanca in that episode
Jesse and Walt disguised in ski masks
kidnaps Saul Goodman and take him to a
freshly dug shallow grave in a remote
part of the desert we watch as Saul
finds himself fearing for his life and
his first instinct is that the
kidnappers are members of the cartel as
you would expect Saul tries to talk his
way out of the situation first he tries
to shift the blame saying no it wasn't
me it was ignacio he's the one then in
Spanish he says he's a friend of the
cartel and then he asked them Lalo
didn't send you know Lalo so from that
exchange two characters from Saul's
backstory are born Ignacio aka nacho and
of course Lalo neither character is
mentioned by name again in Breaking Bad
but it is implied later in a
conversation between Gus and Hector that
Lalo is no longer alive in season 4
episode 11 Gus goes to visit Hector at
Casa tranquila after killing off Don
Eladio and the other leaders of the
cartel he tells Hector that his grandson
Joaquin was killed as well and that
since he was the only family he had left
to Salamanca family name will die with
Hector in his business dealings and
personal obsession with the family Gus
would be better informed on whether Lalo
was still around and Saul Saul is
clearly afraid of him and believes he's
still alive in that moment
when they're in the desert but based on
what Gus said to Hector
we know Lal those days are numbered he
could even die during better call Sol's
timeline just as long as it happens in a
way that Jimmy doesn't know about it and
that's not a very big stretch
considering when people commit murder
they usually try to keep it a secret
while all of this is intriguing enough
in a show that has no shortage of crazy
and/or violent criminals
what makes Lalo stand out from the crowd
through the first four seasons of better
call Saul and the Prix Lalo days the bad
guys in the show had been contained to
one side of the show or the other we had
the Jimmy McGill's law career side of
the show where his brother Chuck was the
main villain on that side Jimmy and Kim
battle with the number of people like
Howard Hamlin and the kettlemans
and then over on the other side we had
the cartel story where Mike and nacho
had to deal with characters like Tuco
and Gus the two stories didn't really
crossover outside of Jimmy and Tuco's
introduction in the first couple of
episodes in season one at the end of
season five we've reached the point
where the show's two sides of the story
have finally come together the legal
side of Kim and Jimmy has collided with
the cartel side of Mike Gus and nacho as
these things come together we need a
villain that can be effective in both
worlds and Lolo seems to be the right
man for the job
Lalo is the guy for this from his first
introduction we can see that he is the
most charismatic Salamanca we've ever
met in that way it's easy to make the
argument that he is the best villain
that better call Saul has produced Chuck
was a great character and the family
dynamic made him a cruel opponent for
Jimmy but he never would have been able
to operate in the cartels world Lalo on
the other hand can sit down with Gus and
Juan bolsa as a representative for his
family but you could also imagine him
being able to strike up a conversation
with Howard Hamlin the other Salamanca
family members we've met our a mixed bag
of crazy and ruthless Tuco which is the
first of the family we met in
bad was a drug-using maniac erratic to
his core the cousins had a laid-back way
in comparison but they seemed to truly
enjoy bringing violence into a situation
when they thought it was necessary
Hector was also erratic and always
appeared to have a chip on his shoulder
that brought things down around him
until he ended up confined to that
wheelchair Lalo is loyal to his family
which is something we know about all the
Salamanca's but he's also clearly
different that's not to say he doesn't
share in some of the family's dark
tendencies he killed Fred from travel
wire without a second thought and the
story he shared with Hector about
burning down a hotel after torturing its
owner was disturbing he's violent and
remorseless but he also seems like he's
got things under control
he's smart and resourceful and we've
seen him stack up as a worthy adversary
for Gus
we've seen them be patient in that area
and methodical to a certain extent he
can also be chatty and friendly and has
the ability to charm people when he
entered the story in season 4
I immediately perked up at the idea of
him breathing life into the cartel side
of the story as interesting as learning
more about Mike and Gus can be that side
of the story started lagging behind
because the stakes just aren't the same
considering we know how their stories
end Lalo presented a real problem for
Gus which got things moving in the right
direction and then once he met Saul we
could see the two stories starting to
come together that's where he gets
really fascinating from my perspective
his charisma and ability to win people
over bears a lot of resemblance to what
makes Jimmy so effective Jimmy / Saul
can do the things he does because even
though he's comfortable getting down in
the dirt with criminals
he still has a straight life that exists
outside the criminal world he has a
criminal nature he commits criminal acts
but he toes the line and his law license
gives him a sense of respectability Lalo
is almost the exact opposite he lives a
criminal existence but can navigate the
other side of the story and even excel
there creating a care
in Lalo that shares many of the same
strengths as Saul creates the perfect
storm Saul can usually talk his way out
of any situation he finds himself in
when Lalo shows up at his door in 509
things are instantly turned upside down
Jimmy isn't able to talk himself out of
this one Lalo once again appears to be
the guy for this he sees right through
Jimmy's lies leaving him defenseless
until the only thing that saves him is
Kim stepping in she's able to use her
skills to neutralize the situation and
in the end he decides to leave we
haven't really met a character who is so
perfectly suited to go up against Jimmy
McGill and as we approach the end game
of Jimmy's transition into Saul Lalo
could really prove to be an important
piece in that puzzle for now we don't
know how long we'll land but either way
he's proven to be one of the most
captivating and infectious characters
that we've come across in the Breaking
Bad universe in short order he brought
excitement into Gus and Mike's side of
the story
delivered some extra humor and more
tension in his quest to make Gus's life
difficult
he became the perfect bridge to bring
both sides of the story together and
emerged as the perfect adversary for
Saul Goodman all at the same time he's
an awful human being and yet you almost
want a root for the guy not knowing how
his story ends keeps things exciting we
expect him to die but there also needs
to be a setup for Jimmy to still be
terrified of him four years from now he
could die in the season 5 finale or he
could die off-screen years later after
the events of Breaking Bad season 2 it
adds an extra dimension and I'm excited
to see where they take it as I said
before I think it's a little early to
put him up at the top of the list of
course right now he's the most exciting
villain in the Breaking Bad universe but
we'll have to see where his story ends
it's the same kind of thing that I think
about when people say which is better
Breaking Bad or better call Saul they're
both different shows and one of them is
complete there's things I like better
about both series but I really wouldn't
pick one over the other until I know how
better call Saul ends so I'm going to
leave it there let me know what you
think about Lalo Salamanca in the
comments how do you think his story will
end as far as coming into the story late
he stacks up pretty well in that
category and Breaking Bad we had Uncle
Jack and Todd they did the job
Todd especially was a pretty good
character but they couldn't really live
up to Gus Lalo came to the game a little
bit later and that gives him an
advantage so drop a comment to tell me
what you think please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon